Aaron Rodgers has found Randall Cobb for
a touchdown more than any wide receivers
been found for it touchdown so far this
year and he joins me right now on the
phone on the rich odds and show how are
you Randall I'm doing great risk for
having you bet so to what do you owe all
of these touchdowns coming a cropper for
you so far this year man I don't know I
guess it's finding a way to get open and
you know find out left for an to come to
you know whenever we get down in the red
zone so you don't say to Aaron I'm open
I think you see me waving my arms around
in their hat when every start scrambling
around how much fun is this for you
based certainly on last year where you
you couldn't play all 16 you weren't
healthy enough is great you know I'm
glad to be back out there with my
teammates back out there doing what I
love to do and you know it's been a fun
year you were rolling right now you know
we got a big win down in Miami this
weekend really looking forward to coming
back home to Lambeau to play the
panthers this weekend so before we get
to this week let's revisit last week the
fake spike that everybody's talking
about we read all about how nobody else
knew that Aaron was was doing that walk
me through that play from your vantage
point Randall uh oh I had just caught a
pass with low ball so I to go down to
catch it and once I caught it I knew we
had to get the spike so getting bought
it a ref I look back at Aaron and he
actually gave me a signal so I knew that
it was a possibility that he was going
to do the fake spike so I ran the route
and he happened to go to other side and
I don't think anybody else knew that he
was going to do the fake spike and I
mean we practice it all the time you
know doing the fake spike just to catch
our defense off guard sometimes in
practice so when he did it you're like
wow he actually did it yeah yeah I think
that's the first time I've actually seen
him do it in a game so you know it's
just him free styling and being a
playmaker that he is and been able to
make a big play for us and at a crucial
time you know just speaking to so many
players as I've been fortunate to do
over the years that I've been with NFL
network and talking to a players who
have played with MVP up
layers and candidates they don't want to
let him down that there's a sense of
camaraderie and there's also a sense of
team but there's also a sense of not
wanting to let Aaron Rodgers down and
you as one of its primary targets what
what has that been like for you being
Aaron Rodgers one of his primary targets
well it definitely it definitely had his
growing pains you know throughout my
career been here with him it took me a
while to get acclimated to him and what
he tries to do with our all fencing and
basically building that trust in that
chemistry with him so but once I built
that trust in chemistry I think we're on
the same page for the most part we have
a good understanding of each other and
know where each other is going to be on
any play so interesting was there a
moment where you you gained his trust
and and things turned where you turned
the corner in that relationship is there
one of those sort of Eureka moments that
you could pinpoint in that I think so i
think in detroit back in 2012 we were
down and it was a big third down for us
i think within 3 minutes left in the
game and you know he came to me on a
corner route and i was able to make a
play for him and I think that was
definitely a turning point and our
chemistry and then our relationship on
the field and there's a bunch of
receivers young receivers on you in your
receiver room who are probably in that
position that you were describing
needing to get into that sort of comfort
zone with Aaron Rodgers are you
counseling these young men like Davante
Adams oh yeah you know I'm telling them
everything that you know I went through
and just just telling them how important
the communication is in practice in the
meeting rooms just walking around the
facility though all those conversations
are very important and he may tell you
something on a Wednesday in week 3 that
doesn't happen in the game until week 10
and he expects you to know that so I
just continued to preach to them how
important those little reminders that he
gave us throughout the week and you know
back in training camp how important
those little things are to hold on to so
we do get in the game time that he's
able to trust you that you're going to
know what that what he's talking about
from weeks back how does somebody from
Knoxville
see wind up in the University of
Kentucky Randall I get that all the time
you know it was a it was a tough
decision but you know it turned out for
the best so it was your decision there
definitely was my decision so why did
you make that decision because I felt
more comfortable with the coaching staff
there was that Kentucky at the time you
know my recruiting coordinator and Randy
Sanders and coach Rich Brooks they did a
great job you know recruiting me and you
know not telling me what I want to hear
but telling me what I needed to hear and
I respected him for him when you were in
Knoxville Tennessee growing up who was
the wide receiver you were admiring my
dad was a big steelers fan so we watched
a lot of steelers games in hinds world
was probably my favorite receiver just
has placed out of the way that he played
with an aggressiveness and a toughness
that you know it was unmatched by a lot
of receivers at that time I don't get to
speak to so many enough world-class
sprinters like you were in high school
Randall I don't know if you've seen my
40-yard dash attempt to combine the last
few years now feed it a few times okay
do you have any tips for me i'd like to
get faster as i get older can you help
me i really don't have too much for you
i think it's going to be hard for you uh
you know what your declining yeah well i
guess your declining speed as you get
older it's kind of tough for you too can
continue to increase your speed well
Randall haters are gonna hate you know
I'm trying to be when I rotators right
now just to motivate you okay I put you
I'm like I'm coming from a different
angle okay I'm like Steve Smith senior
you know what I ain't like I suck this
up I soak this up and I think I'm i
think i'm gonna i'm gonna use this if
you don't mind I hope you do I hope you
do this is the reason that I'm doing it
so you can use it so you can have that
motivation whenever you're out training
I guess you would train like the week
before oh no i've been training right
now oh are you yeah literally as I sit
here I'm doing ab exercises while
talking to you I'm doing manual retches
alone yeah I'm doing mental reps are you
doing a hip-hop from the commercial yes
I'm doing that that's exactly what i'm
doing i got you Randall thanks very much
good luck this weekend against Carolina
which as you know is
very stout opponent so good luck to you
on that front moving forward all right
rich thanks appreciate it you bet that's
Randall Cobb the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience